please be seated
good afternoon today
it's my great honor and it really is an
honor
to add to my national security team
leader of extraordinary courage
character
experience and accomplishment and a man
who i've seen some of the
more interesting parts of the world with
when i was vice president
someone with whom i have worked closely
for many years
and i've seen perform to the highest
standards under intense pressure
someone who i hold in the highest
personal regard
as a man of great decency and a man of
dignity
in my judgment there's no question that
he is the right person for this job
at the right moment leading the
department of defense
at this moment in our nation's history
he's led major coalitions of allies and
partners
to fight terrorism and it took some real
diplomatic capacity to get that done
he's overseeing some of the most complex
logistical efforts
ever undertaken by the united states
military
helped end the war and literally bring
tens of thousands of troops
home safely he's loved by the men and
women
of the armed forces feared by our
adversaries
known and respected by our allies and he
shares my
deeply held belief in the values of
america's alliances
and he is uh just as committed as i am
to rebuilding and modernizing those
alliance
from the asia pacific to europe and
around the world
through sheer determination and
extraordinary skill
he's been breaking down barriers and
blazing the trail forward in this nation
for many years now for more than 40
years
and he has a long way to go and he's
going to do it again
and so today i'm honored to nominate
former general lloyd austin
as a 28th secretary of defense
i want to thank you general your friend
but i want to thank you
general austin for once more stepping
forward
to serve your nation this is not a a
post he sought but i sought him
and i want to thank you and your family
for once again
sharing you with our country and thanks
charlene
today i know how proud
all of uh they all are of you
all four of your children your older
sisters and your brother i knew the
reason why you were a good man you had
to have sisters
to raise you along the way right i know
mine did me and she's much younger
and and your incredible wife charlene
and i mean that sincerely
tomorrow i'm told that jill and charlene
are going to spend some time
together sending off packages to our
soldiers abroad
she and jill are both passionate about
supporting military spouses and families
and i know they'll be a powerful
advocate
for that community together and uh you
know
they're going to both be working at the
white house and the defense department
together
to make sure our families are castro
said before general
america only has many obligations one
sacred obligation
to care and equip those we send to war
care for their families
when they're gone and to care for them
when they come home and their families
i got to know general olson during my
early days as vice president
president obama had charged me with
overseeing the end of operation iraqi
freedom
and ensuring the orderly withdrawal of
our forces and equipment from iraq
general austin was with me on the ground
not just for meetings with troops or for
military strategy sessions he was there
when i was working with iraq political
leaders i watched his political skill
how he dealt with them
they respected him across the board when
i met with the leaders of our
coalition partners the same thing and he
was there
during one particularly memorable
incident
when we were at a meeting at the
ambassador's residence in the green zone
the insurgents lost launched a rocket
attack on the house
and of course general austin was just
another day at the office
he just sat there kept right on going so
i sat there and kept right on going
and everyone or what in the hell are
they doing but you know
he's cool under fire inspiring
the same and all those around him
that's lloyd austin he was the person
president obama and i entrusted with the
incredible task
of bringing home america's forces and
redeploying
our military equipment safely out of
iraq
it was the largest logistical operation
undertaken by the army
in 60 years getting it done required
much more than military know-how
general austin was a diplomat it was not
an easy task
he built relationships with our iraqi
counterparts
and with our coalition partners he was a
statesman representing our country
with the skill at uh at
that uh you know at tables that i've sat
with him
with foreign leaders and i wondered
whether or not he was from the state
department or from the defense
department
both military and civilians i'm not
exaggerating
he has a way about him and always above
all he's looked out for his people
that's why he was known as the soldier's
leader
in this time in the united states army
lloyd austin met
every single challenge with
extraordinary skill and profound
personal decency he's the definition
of duty honor country
and at every step he challenged the
institutions that he loves to grow
more inclusive and more diversive
he was a 200th person ever to retain the
rank of a four-star general
but only the sixth african-american to
ever do that
he was the first african-american
general officer to lead the army corps
in combat he was the first
african-american to command an
entire theater of war and if confirmed
he'll be the first african-american at
the helm of the defense department
in well over 200 years
another milestone and he's a barrier
breaking career has been like this
throughout his career
lloyd austin retired from the military
service more than four years ago
but the law states that an officer must
have left the service
seven years before becoming secretary of
defense
there's a good reason for this law that
i fully understand and respect
i would not be asking for this exception
if it had not if i did not believe
this moment in our history didn't call
for it it does call for it
and if i didn't have the faith i have in
lloyd austin to ask for it
i believe in the importance of civilian
control of the military
so does the secretary designee austin
he'll be bolstered by a strong and
empowered civilian sector
and senior officers senior officials i
should say
working to shape dod's policies and
ensure that our defense policies
are accountable to the american people
civilian military dynamic that dynamic
itself has been under great stress
the past four years and i know that
secretary
destiny austin is going to work
tirelessly to get it back
on track i have personally worked with
this man
i've seen him lead american fighting
forces on the field of battle
i've also watched him faithfully carry
out the orders of the civilian
leadership of this nation
there's no doubt in my mind not any
doubt whatsoever
whether this nominee will honor respect
and on a day-to-day basis breathe
life into the preeminent principle of
civilian leadership over military
matters in our nation
i know this man i know his respect for
our constitution
i know his respect for our system of
government so just as they did for
secretary jim mattis
i asked the congress to grant a waiver
for secretary designee austin
his many strengths and his intimate
knowledge of the department of defense
and our government rey
are i think are are uniquely suited
for the challenges we face now the
crisis we face now
he is the person we need at this moment
in my view
and given the urgent threat and
challenges of our
nation's forces he should be confirmed
swiftly
we need his experience in large-scale
logistical operations to help support
the swift and equitable distribution
of covet 19 vaccines we need his
experience
building and managing relationships
engaging in diplomacy with our partners
to help rebuild america's alliance and
strengthen our shared security
and we need his first-hand knowledge of
the immeasurable cost of war
and the burden it places on our service
members and their families
to help bring to an end the forever wars
and ensure
that the use of force is the last tool
in our toolbox the last tool resorted to
to protect our national security not the
first
we need his deep understanding of the
pentagon to help reform the defense
department
we need his personal experience helping
inform our efforts to ensure that our
armed forces reflect the full strength
and diversity
of our nation that black latino asian
american native american
women men lgbt service members
are treated with dignity and respect
you know at a time when more than 40
percent of our act
more than listen more than 40 of our
active duty forces
are people of color it's long past time
that the department's leadership
reflects that diversity and we need his
in-depth understanding of what it takes
to
deter threats wherever they arise
and to defend the american people our
vital interests and our allies
from harm just as he did when he did
when he was
designated to lead the strategy they
had together with a dozen of partner
nations to uh
ultimately crush isis
if you don't think that required some
diplomatic skill putting that
group together then you don't understand
what was going on
he did a heck of a job threats we face
today
are not the same as though we faced 10
years ago or even five years ago
we must prepare to meet the challenges
for the future of the future
not keeping not just keeping fighting
wars
of the past we must build a foreign
policy that leads with diplomacy
revitalizes the state department
revitalizes our alliances
putting american leadership back at the
table and rallying the world to meet
global threats
of our security from pandemics to
climate change
from nuclear proliferation to refugee
crises
as part of our diverse national security
leadership team
lloyd austin knows how to do this work
before i turn the potential over to the
secretary designee austin
i want to end on a note of personal
privilege
as a leader general austin has always
followed the advice given to him
by his first platoon sergeant as my son
beau biden was a major in the military i
said now you're a field grade officer
dad he said i don't have any illusions
dad
he said i know who runs the united
states army platoon sergeants
and here's what his platoon sergeant
told him quote
if you focus on your people take care of
them
get out in front and lead them they'll
refuse to let you fail
end of quote that's why he's inspired so
many young people who work for him
and give their very best to live up to
his example
leadership including for a time
a young lawyer serving a year in iraq as
a captain with his delaware national
guard unit
my son beau biden i know how proud beau
was to serve
on the general staff general lawson
staff
and i know that under your leadership
general the department of defense will
advance the
security of the american people in ways
that always always
always honor our highest values and
ideals
so i thank you again you know
god bless america and may god protect
our troops
and now i'd like to turn it over to
general austin the
secretary designee for the department of
defense
mr president-elect and madam vice
president-elect
harris thank you for your trust and your
confidence
and for the opportunity to serve as a
28th secretary
of defense and if confirmed by the
united states senate
it will be my sincere honor and
privilege
to return to the department and to lead
our great service members and civilians
in accomplishing the mission of ensuring
our nation's security
you know back in 1877
a young man from the small town of
thomasville georgia
henry ossian flipper became the first
african-american to graduate from the
united states military academy
at west point and after his
commissioning he was assigned to one of
the army's all-black regiments
and he became the first non-white
officer to
lead the buffalo soldiers of the 10th
cavalry
and so fast forward to today
nearly 150 years later
another native son of thomasville
georgia
stands before you as the secretary of
defense
design
now many people have paved the way for
me
and countless others over the years to
include
henry o flipper and i am supremely
grateful to all of them for their
courage
for their determination and for for the
example that they set throughout
and they include the tuskegee airmen
and the montford point marines
and many others
and throughout throughout my career i've
also been incredibly fortunate to
benefit from the support and the
mentorship
of exceptional leaders like
general colin powell
and admiral mike mullen
and general johnny wilson and my old
platoon sergeant who you heard the
president-elect just talk about you know
i was a brand new second lieutenant
and sergeant first class fox ballard
took me in
and taught me the way of the world so i
owe him and many others a great deal and
as sir isaac newton famously said
if i have seen a little further it is by
standing on the shoulders
of giants
i've been very fortunate to have the
love and support of my family as well
my mother and father who was a
postal worker who along with a number of
my uncles and other relatives
spent time in the military and that
inspired my own desire to serve
i've also enjoyed the strong support of
my brother and four older sisters
four older sisters
and most importantly most importantly my
bride charlene
who i've been truly lucky to have by my
side all these years
and i am so grateful for her
enduring love and for her support
you know i spent much of my military
career tackling tough issues and
formidable adversaries in challenging
parts of the world
and president-elect biden as you
mentioned we've worked closely together
on some tough issues and we've got to
know each other under some intense and
high pressure
situations and sir you can expect
that as secretary of defense said i will
give you the same direct
and unvarnished counsel that i did back
then
i understand the important role of the
department of defense and the role that
it plays in
maintaining stability and deterring
aggression
and defending and supporting critical
alliances around the world
including in the asia pacific
in europe and around the world and i
fervently believe that
as you've said before sir that america
is strongest when it
works with its allies
and over the years i've worked
hand-in-hand with our
diplomatic colleagues and partners
around the globe and witness firsthand
what we're able to accomplish together
and so if confirmed i look forward to
resuming this important work
my career has taught me something else
equally fundamental to who we are as a
nation
when i concluded my military service
four years ago i hung up my uniform for
the last time
and went from being general lloyd austin
to lloyd austin it is an important
distinction
in one that i make with utmost
seriousness
and sincerity
and so i come to this role this new role
as a as a civilian leader
with military experience to be sure but
also with a deep appreciation
and reverence for the prevailing wisdom
of civilian control
of our military i
recognize that being a member of the
president's cabinet
requires a different perspective
and unique responsibilities from a
career in uniform
and i intend to keep this at the
forefront of my mind
and i look forward to surrounding myself
with experienced
capable civilian appointees and career
civil servants
who will enable healthy
civil military relations grounded in
meaningful
civilian oversight
as secretary of defense
my priority will always
always be the men and women
military and civilian who make up the
department
and their families and i've seen what
they're capable of great americans like
your son sir
bo and also our future first lady
dr biden in her tireless work for
military families
as the president-elect said beau was one
of the military lawyers on my staff in
iraq
and we stayed in touch and saw each
other a few times after he returned home
and as you too can attest madam vice
president
elect bo was a very special person
and a true patriot and a good friend to
all
who knew him
over the past four decades i've
witnessed our service members and
civilians
selflessness and patriotism and the
extraordinary links that they will go to
in support of the mission and in support
of one another
and i could not be more proud of them
and their families
and if confirmed it will be the honor of
my lifetime to lead them again
with honor and integrity
thank you again mr president-elect and
madam vice president-elect for this
opportunity
and for your trust and confidence in me
may god bless and keep safe all those
currently serving in harm's way
and may god continue to bless the united
states of america
thank you
good afternoon president-elect biden and
i will take office at a consequential
moment for our country
even as we work to contain this pandemic
and responsibly open our economy we also
need
to lead the defense department into the
future rebuild
and renew global alliances and
partnerships
and make sure the united states is
prepared to address new threats
and new challenges from cyber to climate
the fundamental responsibility of our
administration
and any administration is keeping the
american people
safe and secure my whole career has been
about keeping americans safe in the
united states senate i have served on
the homeland security and intelligence
committees
i've traveled to iraq and afghanistan
and the middle east
where i've seen the extraordinary
training commitment
and heroism of our service members
and proudly represented california the
state with the largest number of active
duty military
and veterans in our country and i am
absolutely confident that general
lloyd austin is the right person
to lead the department of defense at
this
critical moment we need a proven leader
to help address this pandemic someone
with the experience to help make sure
safe and effective vaccines are
distributed
equitably to all a leader
who will honor the service and sacrifice
of those who wear the uniform of the
united states
provide for their well-being and make
sure they
and their families are treated with the
dignity and respect
they have earned and a leader
who recognizes that our service members
represent america around the world
and must uphold our nation's highest
values
and ideals general austin
is that leader as the president-elect
noted
this is a milestone nomination a
seasoned highly decorated and trail
blazing commander general austin
reflects the very best
of our nation and president-elect biden
and i will work closely with him
and our entire team of national security
and foreign policy leaders
to make sure the united states of
america is safer and more secure
than ever before you know throughout
america's history
the united states military has been a
home for generations
of young men and women dedicated to
serving
our country and general austin is among
them
with this nomination he will continue
his service
strengthening not only america's
national security
but our role as a partner to allies
around the world and we couldn't be more
proud
thank you
okay